damals lud herzlich willkommen ja heute
meine damen und herren zu einem neuen
video auf meinem kanal auf welchem sonst
extrem viele von euch haben wir den
letzten wochen in meine kommentare
geschrieben hey luca du musst unbedingt
mal auf edelight auf reiche gönner
reagieren ganz kurz ich weiß das video
geht erst eine sekunde auf als er die
gelder nicht kennen sollte die macht
beauty produkte also make-up skincare et
cetera und dadurch ist die milliardärin
geworden dennoch schaltet sie vier
anzeigen in ihrem video ganz kurz willst
du die kamera vielleicht noch mehr vor
deinem gesicht halten
ja ich habe heute auch so viele meetings
haben meeting mit einem frühstück mit
meiner mutter dann nachher noch mit
meinem bett sie redet mit ihrer tochter
und das hört sich an wie ein horrorfilm
was gibt es geht ja auch versteht mich
bitte nicht falsch ich habe nichts gegen
kylie jenner ich habe mehr respekt vor
dem was sie sich aufgebaut hat die
riesiges unternehmen natürlich klar
wurde sie auch irgendwie reich geboren
und in die wege geleitet und so weiter
und so fort allerdings möchte ich
einfach komplett und voreingenommen auf
dieses video reagiert und ich glaube
jetzt sieht sie erst mal ihre tochter an
ok jetzt suchen das outfit für den liner
leiter
[Musik]
ja ich glaube es ist im kind scheißegal
ob es etwas schwarzes oder was wahr ist
dass das ist ja mein gott ich dachte
gerade das sind ihre haare alt habe das
sind irgendwelche aber dennoch frage ich
mich fast jetzt gerade passiert wird er
jetzt das genick gebrochen
sie hat allein zwei leute die ihr ihre
haare davon ablenken dass da keine spray
reinkommt drehen wir die kamera um
nun versteht nicht super also mal ganz
kurz ich glaube dieses kleid kostet mehr
als ein komplettes leben
das sind alles nur ihre taschen kein
scheiß meine erste wohnung hier in köln
war kleiner als ihr seid taschen eine
tasche vielleicht bist du bei mir ist es
so
also ich hab jetzt keine richtigen
taschen aber jetzt mal aufs portemonnaie
bezogen ich gucke in einen schrank
unterliegt dann mein portemonnaie und
das ist halt ja schwarz und ist mein
portemonnaie kaya allerdings schaut in
ihren strand und denkt sich so nämlich
heute schwarz oder schwarz weiß blau
gelb hier noch mal pink noch mal eine
gelbe hier nochmal eine farbe daher oder
eine von denen die vordere da kann man
auch mal klatschen
aber gut wie bereits gesagt das war
überhaupt nicht gegenteil idm ich finds
nur krass was sie da alles für unfassbar
viele und teure dinge in ihrem haus htm
aber sie fährt jetzt ja zu ihrem
meetings rolls-royce bei jedem anderen
menschen ist es morgens sofa was nämlich
denn heute fahrrad oder gehe ich zu fuß
oder nämlich den bus und bei kylie auch
die sieht ja ihre 40 autos und
entscheidet sich dann heute mal nur für
den rolls royce natürlich automatisch
zugpferd der rolls royce vor wahnsinnig
schön und zwei parkplätzen parken
diamanten oben im verdeck dieses video
hat mir bisher nicht gezeigt die den
alltag aussieht sondern vielmehr wie arm
ich eigentlich doch bin nur durch die
haare streichen und keine antworten
darauf
[Musik]
er sieht einfach beschützen also kein
geld aus wie im haus raus sieht ihre
tausenden autos so sagt auch heute
scheine ich mich für den 500.000 euro
wagen dann hat sie allerdings
eingebrochen ist
so macht das denn bitte sein
ach du kacke das ist das sind 6
fernsehen darüber ist gerade ihre karre
gefahren hier rolls-royce jetzt mit
ihrer tochter dies aber echt süß
ich glaube dass er mit travis scott
zusammen entweder travis scott oder acer
brock ich weiß gar nicht genau
und dass selbst ihr kennt hat
lamborghini ihr kommt so ein bisschen so
vor als hätte keine dieses video einfach
nur gemacht und alle leute zu zeigen hey
ich bin reich zu managen life and work
life
heidi du bist milliardären geh doch
einfach in rente
sie hatten eine person die für sie die
knöpfe drückt im fahrstuhl
ja gut sie hat es geschenkt das ist
irgendwie ein bisschen komisch das was
sie sagt ich so daran gewöhnt dass du
das immer für mich machst du auf dein
leben klar
an der stelle wird das heutige video ist
allerdings auch beenden meine lieben
freunde ganz ganz viele von euch haben
wir einfach in meiner letzten videos
immer wieder angepasst sind hey luca du
musst auf kylie jenner a day in the life
reagieren das habe ich nun heute hiermit
getan
ich möchte noch mal und ich weiß das
habe ich jetzt in diesem video auch
schon drei mal gesagt er allerdings
möchte ich noch einmal klarstellen dass
ich überhaupt nichts gegen kyle chandler
habe ich habe riesigen respekt davor was
sie sich für eine brennt aufgebaut hat
allgemein was für ein leben sie führt
aber in diesem video war nicht einige
aussagen wo ich mir gedacht habe kylie
das ist schon ein bisschen komisch wenn
ich meine wii action gefallen hat das
unbedingt einen daumen hoch unter dem
video hier da und schreibt mir mal bitte
in die kommentare
videos auf die ich eventuell als
nächstes reagieren soll eventuell wieder
irgendwelche reichen kinder oder
irgendwas anderes von kylie jenner oder
irgendwas komplett anderes schreiben das
gerne in die kommentare abonniert main
kanal falls noch kein teil der lose zeit
ist es kostenlose verpasst keine videos
mehr liegt unter dem video auf
abonnieren oder kylie macht eine
handtasche aus dir
[Musik]